idris i think you've made a lot of great
choices in your career
i don't know signing up to play a cowboy
when you have an allergy to
horses what's the best idea how'd that
go did you did you know beforehand
did you know before in the ideology uh
you know i signed up to be a producer
and help the film just
you know get some life and then you know
realize that i was gonna be i
want to play uh i do know that i have a
i have an allergic reaction to cats you
know so
let alone horses but here's and that's
no pun
but hey um this is um one of those
moments that i just realized that
i could put my uncomfortability aside
for something
way bigger and that's exactly what we
did you know
yeah that's awesome yeah how did you
find the horses did you have experience
before this with horses at all yeah i
thought the horse was great um but i
didn't have any i mean the last time i
had experience before the filming was
my sister's sixth birthday party i was
i was um that was it but you know riding
with the horses
uh training with them for a month was an
experience you know um
when you when you when you're with the
horse you think is just you don't
coming on to training with horses i
thought it was just you know you ride
the horse you get on and you just you
know yeehaw
into the sunset but it's deeper than
that like you have to build like this
connection this bond with the horse once
the horse is good with you you're good
with the horse and the ride is easy
right yeah that's awesome
so it just talk to me about caleb so
kim's a younger actor but i mean he's a
veteran at this point with all the work
that he's done so what was your
impression
of working with him mckayla you just
have to sit there and listen to this so
yeah it just learned your thoughts on
[Music]
he knows how i feel about him i was a
fan um you know first time i seen caleb
was on stranger and was blown away
you always see talent uh i always keep
an eye out for good actors and i was
like wow that kid's
amazing and then when we met you know i
was so like they say don't meet your
heroes right because you know you might
be disappointed i wasn't at
all and then you know he came with such
ferocity in his approach to working you
know
it was interesting to watch him coming
out of television into a
film world he felt a little bit of out
of depth for him
you know his comfortability was used to
in the same way that
coal was the same and we talked about
that a little bit
and we sort of tried ways to encourage
each other to harness our personal
feelings into our role and you know
caleb was incredible to work with man
and he killed this role like everyone
was like
he killed that and so i'm very proud
that i had the opportunity to be there
and watch that
hey yeah and caleb i was thinking you're
amazing in this caleb and yeah watching
i was thinking you know a lot of actors
child actors struggle to make that
transition to adult roles
and then also too like when you come out
with a big project like stranger things
you get boxed in
so how are you finding getting different
roles for yourselves
um you know uh i yeah people a lot of
people definitely talk about that a lot
i mean i probably
i didn't even really have a problem with
trying to find those roles for me
because i i mean i'm still working on
stranger things and i was able to do
a project while i was filming strangers
well not while i was spending while i
was still on the show
but um i think you know when i didn't
really look at the
look at it that way i think it was just
i had i love acting and i fell in love
with the art so it was just the
dedication of just wanting to
do projects that i felt connected to and
i didn't worry about what other people
thought like oh he won't transit to
an adult actor or do anything else i
mean i knew
i know that people think that i am lucas
and people think that's all i can do but
i know my range and i know where
i can go so um i didn't have that in the
way i just knew
that um once um you know once i got on
this project i was able to show my range
yeah and people are gonna be blown away
when you see you killed yeah this movie
was absolutely awesome i really really
enjoyed this movies guys
congratulations thank you very much
thank you very much have a great day